hey guys today I'm going to talk about
possibility of raider Targaryen
appearing in season seven in mono branch
flashbacks of course rengar who's
mentioned in ten episodes so far
according to many sources and according
to some kind of proof might finally
appear in solve a lot of unexplained
events rageh Targaryen known as the Last
Dragon the nurse's brother and John's
father demand that everyone is blaming
for starting Robert's rebellion by
kidnapping and apparently raping Lyanna
Stark demanded of skill by Robert might
finally appear which would explain a lot
yet while it will give us an answer to a
lot of unexplained questions and would
be nice for us fans to finally see
exceedingly intelligent noble kind
skills tones handsome Prince of
Dragonstone who beside all of this was
talented musician and was loved by the
small folk let's consider the clues that
are pointing on razors appearance in the
upcoming season this rumor starting
folding around with casting for season
seven in which one specific casting call
fits perfectly with draggers ex [ __ ]
ssin the casting call required an actor
who would portray young lord in his late
twenties his tall handsome young lord
and the show is looking for a white
actor who uses DRP accent he is
scheduled to shoot in two week
commencing September 20th the age body
type and handsomeness definitely seemed
to fit regular description while the RP
accent aka received pronunciation also
referred to as the Queen's English is
the English accent often used around
King's Landing in Game of Thrones which
also fits rather not only that we have
this casting call is some kind of proof
but we also have an actor that might
portray Rhaegar is Devin Oliver who kind
of confirmed his role with sharing the
photo of himself on his personal
Instagram with the caption I may or may
not have made an appearance in Game of
Thrones season 7 it's also important to
highlight that Game of Thrones has a
long history of featuring musical guest
stars in small parts members of Coldplay
of monster Sandman and Snow Patrol are
just a few musicians that popped up into
Westeros over the years which leaves an
open possible
Leo folliver appearing and keeping the
tradition alive in season seven by
playing a small role part which most of
us would miss as most of us there with
those musicians that appeared on the red
wedding as a drummer and there's a
totally unimportant ordinary soldier
while Davin Oliver might appear in cameo
role there are a few clues that are
going favored to rumors about Oliver
portraying the Last Dragon
rageh as you'll know Rhaegar is known
for three things for his beauty his
skills on the battlefield and his talent
in music for his love for singing the
most important connection between Oliver
and dragger is in fact that both of them
are talented musicians in the books it
is noted that Rhaegar once sang a song
so nicely that it made Lyanna stark drop
a tear while in show sir Barse Selmy
revealed it to Daenerys just before his
death revealed that Rhaegar never liked
killing although he was good at it but
instead he loved singing sir Barristan
also shared his memories with Daenerys
and said the treasure used to every now
and then disguise himself as a minstrel
and sang on the streets of King's
Landing while he stood the guard and
made sure no one killed his prince while
Oliver is an American musician part of
the American band I see stars Rhaegar
was talented musician in Westeros which
could also be considered some kind of
confirmation beside this musical
connection between those two Oliver also
just like Rhaegar from his forming bond
likes to his body build if this rumor
ends up as the truth if Oliver is really
going to portray Rhaegar and the Fragger
is going to appear in brands flashback
in my opinion we're going to see a
flashback of a great tourney at
Harrenhal I don't know if just me but I
don't believe that rugger who was known
as a kind person
kidnapped Liana whereupon he raped her
in order to fulfill a prophecy in order
to give a bird to his son
I would like to sear a garden bran
flashback of a tourney at Harrenhal
which I'm almost sure we will since I'm
expecting for showrunners to explain to
us how Jon's parents fell in love and
why they decided to run away to explain
to us what was that much important for
them to leave without explanation to put
seven kingdoms into the state of chaos
to start a rebellion I'm expecting for
sure runners to show us the currently
unknown reason which led the heir to the
Iron Throne Prince Rhaegar - ran away
with Liana
since I don't believe that as the most
honorable man in the Seven Kingdoms sir
bars of sell me describe dragger himself
as kind and friendly kidnapped and raped
Liana I'm wondering what was that
important for them to run away without
an explanation the event which resulted
with Liana father and brother being
killed while rehgar along with his
father wife and two children were also
killed if you're wondering why am i
refusing possibility of rehgar
kidnapping and raping Liana it's very
simple so let's just put it this way
Lyanna stark was known as the she-wolf
because like her niece Arya she was
courageous fierce and stubborn well she
was also most likely a mystery knight of
the Laughing tree the idea that to be
honest start with a low someone -
kidnapper without putting a fight
doesn't make any sense while on the
other hand I can see the most loved kind
Prince Rhaegar kidnapping Liana and
raping the same girl it just doesn't
make any sense to me in my opinion and
I'm sure most of you would agree Rhaegar
and Lyanna fell in love in a lot of this
result is with that for both of them
along with majority of their families
now let me explain to you how that last
happened which is also very simple and
probably a few of you who thought about
this cam already came to this conclusion
by this theory it all started with the
tourney at Harrenhal which Howland Reed
a bannermen of how stark little
dishonored by three Squires well those
three Squires were bullying Lord Reed
Liana came to his defense and baited up
those three Squires whereupon she
invited Colin to share table with her
and her brother said the feast that
knight say Knight mature a girl played
one of his sad beautiful songs on his
harp which made Liana cry a couple of
days later a short mystery Knight
challenged and defeated three night
school Squires had bullied Colin read
the same night by this theory knight of
the Laughing trees Lyanna stark and
that's how love between her and noble
Rhaegar
and if you're wondering about clues of
this mystery night Bingley and a start
there are a few the knight of the
Laughing tree were short was having the
booming voice which was a man's voice
was having mismatched armor which means
that the night and have access to
regular armor which telltale marking on
it Ward we would image on shield which
implies the connection to the old gods
in the north and it's final confirmation
this night challenged and fought only
against those night school Squires
bullied Colin read same man that Liana
defended a few days before you might be
confused now and your problem on ring
what Liana being the knight of the
Laughing tree has to do with ragaar how
then a stark and rhaegar met each other
and how did they fall in love
well ragaar figured out who mysterious
night was the tourney at Harrenhal was
the first time after the good amount of
years in which the King Aerys had led
the Red Keep and because he was paranoid
known as the Mad King he thought that
mystery Knight aka Anna was the enemy
and that the same night wanted to kill
him which led him to send his son
dragged her out in order to find it same
night in a short amount time
Rhaegar brought the mysterious night
shield to his father Aerys with report
that is all he found by this theory
Rhaegar lied Rhaegar found his Jewish
knight of the Laughing tree and
discovered that it was this young fierce
less beautifully and start the pet stood
up for her Bannerman for same Bannerman
that she defended a few days before
Rhaegar couldn't bring her to his father
since he knew how it would end with her
being burned alive noble and kind Prince
couldn't do anything but to take her
shield and reported his spotter that
it's all he found if this year is going
to be revealed as a true one in the
upcoming season could also explain why
the champion of the joust the champion
of this tourney at Harrenhal Rhaegar
Targaryen chose Lyanna stark is the new
queen of love and beauty
why Rhaegar instead of his own wife gave
a crown of love into roses to Liana
this was the beginning of their love
Liana fell in love the handsome heir of
the throne the man that was loved by
everyone the man that was good at
everything he chose to do while ragu
fell and loved it fearless and beautiful
Liana at the moment in which he found
the mystery Knight in the moment in
which he protected Liana by lying to his
father this was the beginning of their
doomed love this same love is the reason
because the wage rag are commanded to
the best swordsman that the Seven
Kingdoms have ever seen commanded to his
best friend Sir Arthur Dayne known as
the sword of the morning along with Sir
Gerald Hightower to protect his beloved
pregnant Liana during Robert's rebellion
in conclusion Devin Oliver will most
likely appear in the upcoming season he
will portray either the Prince of
Dragonstone the man known for his
kindness the man that was loved by
everyone from highborn
to the small fold Rhaegar Targaryen or
will play a small role that we won't
even notice part which most of us would
miss as most of us did with those
musicians that appeared earlier in Game
of Thrones
let me know your opinion about Devin
Oliver portraying Rhaegar and also let
me know in which brands flashback would
you like to see him is it flashback as
tourney at Harrenhal or is it maybe
flashback off Rhaegar and Lyanna being
happy at the top of joy or even maybe
something else let me know your thoughts
about all of this in the comment section
down below I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if it is make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]
you